acabamos de deducir las ecuaciones de
corriente y voltaje de la respuesta
natural de un circuito rc ahora lo que
hice fue tomar estas ecuaciones y usar
excel para graficar las y aquí les voy a
mostrar estas gráficas hagamos un
ejemplo muy rápido aquí con valores
reales para ver cómo funciona esta
ecuación aquí tenemos mil oms en nuestra
resistencia y se es igual a un micro
farah
r por se es igual a 10 a la 3 por 10 al
menos 6 y es 10 a la menos 3 segundos o
un milisegundo este es el producto de r
por c y se me estaba olvidando b 0
digamos que tenemos 2 volts en este
capacitor de inicio así y ahora decimos
que bt es igual a de 02 volts por el ala
menos t / r por sé que es un milisegundo
y esta es la respuesta natural para este
circuito ahora veamos cómo luce en este
lado tenemos vedete que es igual a 2 por
el ala menos t entre un milisegundo
vemos que comienza en 2 volts
y disminuye como predijimos y esta es
una curva exponencial de este otro lado
como dijimos antes y comienza en cero
cuando la corriente en el capacitores
cero y en cuanto cerramos el interruptor
la carga sale y pasa a través de la
resistencia y esta es la ecuación y dt
igualados entre mil por el ala menos t /
r por c
o menos te entre un milisegundo y esta
es la respuesta natural de un circuito
rc y se van a encontrar con esto en casi
todos los circuitos que construyen